[Music]
it comes partly in smoke
from the festival toilets
which were collected
so obviously with the soaring price
of fertilizers this type of
fertilizer fertility which comes from
urban areas obviously takes over a major interest
for provided that there is  has
availability which for the moment
practices are not the case
[Music]
the yield was almost equivalent and
the quality of the beans was good
in fact we have rather positive feedback
from people minimum surprised but in
any case from the point of view  seen the
daily use the nice ones sees only few
differences compared to a
traditional system in fact
[Music]
where